Oh,
I'm leaving Patriot on January 16th.
Some of you may know that that's I suppose in protest over their treatment of
Carl Benjamin,
uh,
perhaps better known as Sargon of the cad.
Um,
patron like many companies seems to believe that their role now is to act as
sensor for speech patterns or speech content that they regarded as unacceptable.
And I think that they made a big mistake with Sargon.
And so both Dave Rubin and I and also Sam Harris decided to leave patriotic and
that's going to be official as of January 15th.
So those of you who are my Patriot on subscribers,
if you're interested in continuing with that subscription,
you can go to my website@jordanbpeterson.com and there's a support button there
in the menu and you can use that system.
I'm also trying to design a system that at least in principle,
might work as a reasonable replacement for patriotic.
Um,
that's a couple of months away,
but we're working hard on it to,
we're getting legal advice.
We're going to set up multiple payment channels so that it won't be easy for
people to be kicked off by credit card companies,
or let's call them,
um,
virtue signaling,
uh,
ethical types who think that their role is to police free speech.
So I think this is a very bad precedent that patron is set and the credit card
companies too,
I can't imagine it's difficult to imagine a more dystopian scenario than to have
the,
uh,
large tech companies in combination with the credit card companies monitor your
spending to decide when what you're doing is sufficiently ethical by their,
by the standards of the people who are running their,
let's call them safety and security,
speech monitoring programs.
It's just such a terrible idea.